On September 19th, 1991,
two hikers traversing the Ötzal Alps
on the border of Austria and Italy
discovered a corpse emerging from the ice.
Researchers soon realized they weren’t
looking at the victim
of a recent climbing accident,
as initially assumed,
but the mummified body of a man
who’d lived about 5,300 years ago,
who they came to call Ötzi the Iceman.
One early theory for Ötzi’s alpine death
was that he was a local shepherd or hunter
who got caught in bad weather and froze.
However, a shocking discovery eventually
revealed his true cause of death
and upended his story.
So, what do we know about Ötzi?
And how did he die?
Over the millennia, the Alpine cold
and sun protected Ötzi’s body
from decomposition,
freezing and drying it out in cycles,
and leaving critical clues
for researchers.
Ötzi was about 160 centimeters tall,
weighed some 50 kilograms,
and died between 40- and 50-years-old.
He led an active life but had
a strong genetic predisposition
for cardiovascular diseases.
His intestines were also parasitized
by whipworms
and his stomach contained
ulcer-causing bacteria,
all of which might have caused
some unpleasant symptoms.
He died hundreds of years before
Stonehenge and the Great Pyramid
were constructed, around 3350 BCE.
Ötzi lived during the late
Neolithic Copper Age,
when metal extraction
and crafting practices
were spreading throughout Eurasia.
Indeed, along with stone arrowheads
and knives,
Ötzi carried an axe made of copper
from what is now Tuscany.
Swaths of his clothing were made
of sheep and goat leather,
and his diet included cultivated grains,
all of which suggested that Ötzi’s people
relied on certain domesticated animals
and crops.
And when researchers
inspected Ötzi’s skin
with light ranging from infrared to UV,
they found a total of 61 tattoos.
Interestingly, the markings corresponded
with areas of Ötzi’s body
where he probably experienced pain,
like from degeneration observed
in his knees, ankles, and spine.
Researchers think that the tattoos
might have been intended as treatment—
perhaps an early form of acupuncture.
Close scrutiny also clarified
the circumstances of Ötzi’s death—
and led to a tantalizing prehistoric
murder mystery.
A decade into studying Ötzi,
a CT scan picked up a crucial detail:
there was a flint arrowhead lodged
in Ötzi’s left shoulder.
Soon enough, researchers started piecing
Ötzi’s final days together.
A deep cut wound on Ötzi’s hand
showed initial signs of healing
and must have occurred
just days before his death.
It was likely a defensive wound
which indicated that Ötzi was attacked
with a sharp blade
but fought back and survived.
Ötzi may have dressed
the wound with bog moss,
which has antiseptic properties
and was found with his remains.
Meanwhile, the types and location
of pollen in Ötzi’s digestive tract
indicated that it was spring
or early summer
and that his last three days were hectic.
Ötzi seemed to be fleeing something.
About 33 hours before his death,
Ötzi was at an altitude
of around 2,500 meters,
near the timber line.
Then, approximately 24 hours later,
he descended to at least 1,200 meters,
to a zone of warmth-loving trees.
In his final hours, Ötzi reached
an altitude of around 3,000 meters
where grasses, sedges,
and certain wildflowers dominated.
His last meal included a large helping
of dried wild ibex, roe deer, and grains.
Then, despite Ötzi’s apparent efforts
to escape the conflict,
someone at a distant vantage
shot him from behind.
The arrow pierced a major artery
and embedded itself in his left shoulder,
causing extensive blood loss.
Ötzi probably died soon after,
his remains and all his belongings left
undisturbed in the glacier for millennia.
This 5,300-year-old cold case has offered
invaluable glimpses into the distant past.
But the mystery of who exactly Ötzi was
and why he was killed
will probably never be solved—
the tangible evidence for the act
degraded and carried away,
lost to snow drifts long ago.